here's how the game works if a
contestant can answer
six questions from six feet away
in 60 seconds they'll win 600
and if they answer less than six
questions correctly
they'll still go home with a fun prize a
six-pack
so it's win-win okay everybody our first
contestant is
meredith hi meredith you ready to play
yeah all right alex start the timer okay
what did justin timberlake and jessica
feel just name their second child
phineas or linus uh
linus nope how many elements are there
in a periodic table
118 or 88. god okay okay okay i knew
this
um what are the choices 118 or 88
118. um yes which one of these
is not an olympic sport badminton or
dodgeball uh
batman no no what was the first vice
president of the united states john
adams or james madison oh i knew i knew
this i knew this i knew this um
it is
what are the choices again john adams
from james madison
james madison nope john adams what breed
of dog is scooby doo
saint bernard a great dean great dane
yes
okay and which one of these temperatures
can water freeze 32 degrees fahrenheit
or 30 30 p.m
fahrenheit yes
ah gosh darn it meredith yeah
okay everybody it's our second
contestant it's christina
all right here we go christina all right
ready
set go okay ant eaters do not
have which of the following teeth or a
sense of smell
uh i know they don't okay since it's now
no it's beef
which solo artist holds the record for
most number one singles mariah carey or
madonna
uh must be madonna it's mariah carey
shockingly enough
which is the only nfl team that has
their logo only on one side of their
helmets the new orleans saints or the
pittsburgh steelers
i'm gonna go ahead and say the saints
which state is in between ohio and
illinois iowa or indiana
um it's gotta be indiana yeah
how many keys does the piano have 78 or
88
darn it one more one more for which film
did steven spielberg win a best picture
oscar each to each year schindler's list
must be ep
no it was [ __ ]
okay how many oceans are there in the
world five or seven
seven five
all right oh yeah you get the token
crappy
stickers thank you drew oh i'm
sorry christina okay what is your name
zara
zara beautiful and the best store
uh oh my gosh zara okay ready i'm really
excited yes oh my god i hope you get
easier questions
all right are you ready alex start the
time all right
where did cats sweat through their paws
or whiskers
whiskers no paws which member of one
direction was the first to leave the
group zayn malik or harry styles
hairstyles
no it was alex what country is directly
north of hungary switzerland or slovakia
slovakia thank god
which of these is a prime number three
or thirty-three
three yeah yep ankle what is it called
when a player makes a one
over par or an individual hole a birdie
or a bogey
over a par one over parker let's face it
you're just gonna get here
it's a boat how long is the great wall
of china 13
171 miles or 17 131
which astrological site is represented
by the scales
pisces or libra waiver those three times
yes
thank god okay
which is prince harry's wife's name
meghan markle or kate middleton
prince harry yes meghan markle yes of
course it is
the asian how many did we get
gosh darn it this game is impossible
thank you so much drew you're a perfect
hero i'm
sorry i'm gonna really enjoy this
these are flower beauty i put a lip
and a cheek in there for you
just buy yourself some cocktails
christina meredith and zara
thank you so much for your time today i
really appreciate it
[Music]
you